this is very new I don't think this is
ever like been doable before I mean
there's been blindfold chest before
we're like the you can hide the pieces
on screen but then no one can see them
what's going on or I could have someone
like helping me where I'm saying the
moves and they're saying what's being
played but to play alone and be actually
blindfolded and be able to type and
being able to stream it where people can
see the pieces I think this is a
somewhat of a first I don't know if this
will go on YouTube they'll probably go
on YouTube at some point well it's a
huge raid from Alexandre botas shout out
to botas 393 people welcome people if
you're just joining I'm doing something
different you've probably joined at the
right time you're you rated it at the
right time actually because there's been
good portions of the stream where I'm
not looking at the chats what's going on
is let's actually go back and start a
new game I'm on leeches dev I'm gonna
just create a game here five five the
first person to accept gets the game I'm
playing PI torch okay beautiful and will
Minotaur will scroll down to fit this in
so I'm I'm gonna depart from looking at
the chats and I'm gonna put on my hoodie
this is a blindfold stream and I'm white
it's my e4 I have to turn on my volume
wait did black move I thought okay black
moves to there so we have a Scandinavian
let's play II d5 wait what he played d5
right why is it not working
II d5 I'm so confused
he takes d5
okay I have to pee cuz I don't know what
happened
oh I played d4 I thought I play d4 okay
I plucked again let's play well London
why my type slipping Bishop f4 Oh I
typed too many things okay I'm trying
here Bishop f4 oh there we go try and
make the smoother yeah my my typing
skills are not as good as my blindfold
skills unfortunately we're only on move
to opponent is probably petrified of the
London he played knight c6 let's play e3
no naughty for e3 e4 is actually an
interesting move though it's for another
gambit I'll pre move t5 this is actually
really interesting efore actually seems
playable it's like an accidental gambits
because after d5 the knight is kicked
i'll just gain space I'll be happy oh do
I have tea where's my tea here's my tea
can drink tea while blindfolded all
right Knight B 4 so the pawns attacked
play Knight c3 defending my D pawn
attacking the e pawn I'm gonna go for
like Bishop either Bishop b5 or Bishop
c4 max and if 6 is a reasonable move
let's play Bishop b5 check to the king
yeah now I play Bishop c4 now the bishop
on d7 is obstructing the Queen from
attacking the pawn I want to play a 3 mm
you played a 6 I think that's not a 6
let's play a 3
and now the night isn't my trapped d5
what is b5 Bishop b3
should be three looks reasonable think
the light's still trapped
ooh counter-attacking I could play f3 I
could play Queen d4 maybe the Queen d4 I
think the light's still trapped I'm
defending c2 with the bishop the Knights
attacked twice pre-move 95i Bishop vana
for such a happy London Bishop yeah this
is a bit easier than the last opponent
it's still a matter of remembering where
things are c5 c5 the counter-attacking
doesn't stop I can just take the pawn
wait if I take the pawn there's be five
but then I can take the other pond and
then Bishop d7 what are these moves I
could on pass on but that doesn't work
let's see 5 is so resourceful Wow
by Queenie 5 but then see for my queen
bee 5 c4 I can take on d5 with a knight
this is so complicated oh [ __ ] zombie 3
okay we'll play queen bee five Queen e5
oh my gosh Queen I've to a sneak peek at
the he 45 the queue is like far in the
corner of the keyboard I think I was
Miss typing there okay so the Knights
still attacked still supposed to be
trapped I'm expecting c4
maybe there's also 9797 I take on e4 I'm
dreaming of like some smothered mate see
ya c4 I wanna like play Knights takes b5
in 96 with some amazing mates it's so
close let's play Knight d5 5 it's gonna
take the bishop probably then I can have
a pleasant choice between night c7 96
and then taking on b4 as well wait
Knight takes d5 it didn't say which
night though both Knights can take on d5
probably the B nights I would assume the
b9 takes one d5 my Bishop is still so a
bishop a four this is weird because now
I have to visualize a position with the
knight on f6 and also with an island b4
because I'm not sure which Knight took
on d5 thankfully I'm threatening me than
one in both of those cases but that's a
bug that needs to be fixed it has to
specify which Knight moves
I would think unless I'm missing
something
thought there's another f6 Queen stolen
ePHI but this is such a strong threat
how does black actually survive this is
Bishop d7 there's still 96 mates
this is so beautiful actually don't have
to see it to appreciate the beauty like
a six and there's Knight c7 double
checkmate
I believe
[Music]
you know I I can't hear or see it but I
can sense my opponent is just suffering
oh I forgot to open the chat or no maybe
I intentionally made sure the chatons is
hidden from me I assume there's mod sir
shout out to the mods and again I don't
know what the time situation is I know
we both started with 5 minutes there is
a 5 second increment so black should be
running low on time
whoa there was a rook what where was a
rook where'd that come from
okay eyeball eye if he has a wreck I
have a rock or not I'm so confused
I don't know what I just allowed their
work a 4i I thought I was meeting but
maybe not so the bishop star on g4 so
let's play like h3 I guess trying to
provoke some sort of blunder if flack
wants to be safe he can play Bishop d7
like cito check oh my gosh King up for
fun what am I doing with my life my
Brooke is gonna fall
the bishop still attacked on g4 yeah
it's h g4 thanks t4 okay
still a fight like there's comp I lost
my light squared bishop which is kind of
annoying but I have an item b5 b6 wait a
minute Queen d6 Knight d6 where's my
Knights I thought I have a nine on b5
unless he played Queen b6 I'm so
confused
97 maybe night c7 I swear I have a 9 on
b5 remind I go
okay I'll play c4 and I can't play c4
what is this position I need to do now
it feels like I'm in a dark room and I'm
just trying to like mind my way around
64
figure out what's going on now my queens
attacks so you're threatening me on f2
probably is queen d4 Queen d7
interesting f3 why can't I play up three
there we go see there's a Pavan c4 what
is this oh my gosh resigned I resigned
that was those just terrible what just
happened there well that ended with like
a boat test gambit I I have so much
extra time wait no I'm not gonna resign
I'm gonna try and win this with looking
at the board
yeah let's mute this need my comb again
okay time to unleash some serious chest
also bits love a chest with bits Oh free
Queen the counter boat has gambits
what's going on why can i move
what Oh my opponent resides
I thought he resigned what is he hung a
queen oh I was all ready to fight I was
more than just a counter go Ted's gambit
it's like you hang a queen and before
the pawn can take it you just resigned
what was that or maybe my opponent was
watching insides gonna look at the board
didn't want to mess with me
moo-cow thanks for subbing was this also
what happened to mine I'll be fine okay
I swear I had an iron b5 he took it take
it I feel like there is a move that I
missed there maybe it was a six no III
definitely acknowledge a six because I
knew the knight was trapped I think I
acknowledge b5 yeah all of the sites saw
I was envisioning the pawns still on a
seven so I took on b5 and then ah so in
this position I thought one of the
Knights took on d5 but it was a takes b5
that really threw me off I was
envisioning this position with a knight
here and the bishop here and the pawns
still here I was so off
yeah the B and E's in two I need to
listen more closely but even maybe if
its side like pawn maybe it should say
pawn so it's a bit more clear do I do
one more
oh no whose clip wait what is this click
oh no oh no was I saying the position
after Bishop a4 was so beautiful this is
so bad
all the apps in the chat so ugly